بعد اسبوع ونصف همم وصف باسبوع الفوضى على
تويتر قلعه محللون ان سياسه الن ماسك مع
تويتر من المرجح ان تفشل لانه يتعامل مع
توتير على انها شركه ناشئه بينما بالحقيقه
هي الشركه ناضجه وفي سوق تنافسيه للغايه
بل وتذهب والسجونل ابعد من هذا وتقول ان
موقع التويتر اصبح مهددا بالفعل بازمه
وجوديه نتيجه الخسائر الماديه الكبيره
اليوميه في كل الاحوال فان ما يفعله ماسك
في نظري الخبراء سلاح ذو حدين يمكن ان
يزيد مكاسب الشركه ويمكن ان يقود الثقه
فيها انجز ماسك في الماضي ما اعتبره
الكثيرون مستحيلا لكن تويتر يعد نوعا
مختلفا تماما من التحدي عما تعمل معه من
قبل وكالعاده مصائب قوم عند قوم فوائده
والمستفيد هنا هو شبكه اجتماعيه صغيره
تسمى ماستودون هذه بعد الموجوده منذ عام
2016 والتي لم يسمع عنها الكثرون ربحت منذ
السابع والعشرين من اكتوبر
230,000 مستخدم وعلى عكس الشبكات
الاجتماعيه الكبيره فان ماستودون مجاني
للاستخدام وخالي من الاعلانات تم تطويره
من قبل منظمه غير حيه مدعومه من التمويل
الجماعي ويقول منشئها يوجين ان المنصه هي
مشروع اكثر من كونها منتجا استهلاكيا ومن
الواضح ان اسماء ذات ثقل تركت التويتر
وانضمت لماستو دون مثل الممثله الكوميدينا
الكوميديه كيف جريفن والصحفيه مولي جون
فاست
[موسيقى]